frozen yogurt stores make twenty one
hundred dollars a day selling 500 cups
at eight ounces each and it was the
business that I almost started instead
of starting my gym so I know a ton about
it and I will tell you how it works and
what you can use from psychology that I
learned from yogurt stores that you can
apply to your business today when I was
21 years old I wanted to be an
entrepreneur and I was deciding between
which business I should start either a
test prep business because I'd done
really well on my standardized tests
Fitness because I was in shape I liked
Fitness people always talk to me about
it and the third was frozen yogurt I did
an extensive amount of research on how
to open a frozen yogurt store a couple
quick things that you may not know about
Frozen your stores in general they on
average make between 750 and 800 000 a
year I thought eight hundred thousand a
year that means I make 800 000 a year
I'm Gonna Be Rich doesn't really work
that way the average store that we're
talking about does 2 000 plus dollars a
day means 328 dollars a day in owner pay
they run margins between 10 and 15
percent the average Menchie's owner for
contacts makes ninety three thousand
dollars a year take home not as sexy as
you might think you've got strawberries
that are going bad you've got machines
that are breaking in the back you've got
hard cost of yogurt you've got a retail
lease that's prominently located with
good signage Good Foot traffic ample
parking like there's lots of other
things that go into this business and on
top of that if you wanted to buy into a
franchise most franchises have six
percent ish of top line that goes
straight to them now that might not
sound like much but if you're running 10
margins that's 60 percent of your take
home
so they have figured out a way to take
the majority of the profit from their
franchisees and what most people don't
know is that franchises will structure
their fees so you make just enough that
you can keep going and maybe if you're a
good operator open another location but
not so much that you're going to get
rich on it so they're only looking to
optimize to beat the return on capital
of the stock market by a decent amount
if the stock market gets you 10 they're
going to try and get 20 to 25 and
they're going to squeeze off the top and
take the rest because of how good their
model is the flip side of that is that
if you are into a franchise you should
be saving enough on bulk purchasing
because they're buying for 200 plus
locations that they can save you on hard
costs of things like yogurt fruit spoons
cups machines Etc the converse of that
though is that many times when you're
starting the franchise they will up
charge you on all of those things
because they're trying to make money too
there's the theory and then there's the
practicality because I went on a site
called rasmus.com it's a business
foreclosure site I got my first gym
equipment from that foreclosure site 13
Grand I sat there and I'd refresh every
week until eventually one came up and I
bought it all the gym equipment from a
gym that went under a franchise won't
let you do that because that's where
they make their money but there are ways
to open these things for cheaper I did a
cursory search on there before this
video and there were three frozen yogurt
stores that were franchises that went
under in terms of I could buy everything
inside the store the most expensive the
three was 20 grand you're trying to get
into this world you want to go open a
restaurant you want to open a gym go
find foreclosure sites now you may have
heard of some of these places Golden
Spoon Yogurtland Menchie's Pinkberry if
you search frozen yogurt store near you
you probably have 30 locations that open
up because there's demand for it the
average cup size is eight ounces that
people will buy the average split
between toppings and yogurt 25 of
people's weight is topping 75 is yogurt
it's best for the store owner to have as
much yogurt as possible in the cup
because the toppings are more expensive
so toppings cost between 10 and 40 cents
per ounce most places charge between 20
5 and 60 an ounce they can even break
even or lose money depending on which
toppings you're getting you get the
fruit it's costing them money but they
make up for it in the fact that yogurt
costs them about eight cents per ounce
and they charge 50 even 60 sometimes
that's where the margin of the business
exists when you're working on margins
that are even like 70 that means that
you have 70 left to cover everything out
so if you want to run a 50 margin
business for example then you'd have to
take 20 of your top line and pay every
other Bill very hard to do for that
twenty one hundred dollars a day they're
selling roughly 500 cups a day of yogurt
on average with an eight ounce cup of
all those brands most of them are
commoditized meaning there's very little
difference between a Menchie's and a
yogurt land and a Golden Spoon it's been
a poorly competed Marketplace solely
done by franchisors who are trying to
sell as many locations as they possibly
could rather than build a brand there is
no Chick-fil-A of the yogurt world
because if there were they'd be
dominating the underlying lesson is that
if you look at any Indus history there
is the potential to have an amazing
business inside of it even if it is a
commodity today you can out-compete them
all you have to do is walk into any
Yogurt Land and see that the floors are
sticky the chairs are all over the place
the cups are a mess sample cups are
strewn on the side the girl behind the
counter is on her iPhone when you walk
in doesn't say hello one of the nozzles
is out it says out of order everywhere
it doesn't take a lot to win most times
just to beat everybody you got to be
better than the bottom 25 and you make
money one of my favorite things that I
learned from one of the big
breakthroughs that I think they had was
actually how they priced ice cream is
usually sold by cup you get a small you
get a medium you get a large they flip
that and made it wait the consumer gets
to pick how much they spend someone
might fill up a cup get to the counter
and see seven dollars and be like ah I'm
such a fat ass rather than when you buy
one off itself and then you see the
seven dollars you're like wow this place
is so expensive because there's an
element of control on the consumer side
they are the ones you to Bear some of
the accountability or responsibility for
that fact the second thing that they did
that I thought was brilliant they used
to have small normal sized cups at
yogurtlands someone I will bet you a few
years ago ran out of small cups
and then people only had the medium and
large cups left and they realized that
at the end of the day their sales
probably went up by 20 or 30 percent and
they wondered I wonder why our sales
went up when you give people a bigger
cup they will fill more of it they're
like oh I guess this is standard the
power of the default option when selling
anything that's why assumed closes and
things like that are so powerful when
you say hey do you want this or this you
can even listen for this at fast food
places they're like hey do you want a
medium or a large coat they have a small
option but they want you to pick between
the larger ones Yogurtland and those
ones went a step further just remove the
small option because it is self-serve
but if you got a small amount of yogurt
in a bucket-sized cup it just looks
weird they did that and by extension
were able to raise the amount of yogurt
that people bought probably by a large
percentage every single time and not
take the blame for it because they're
the one with the hand on the nozzle
you'll also note that the order in which
they present the items are reverse order
of the cost to them so they start you
with the cheapest option this is exactly
how buffets work too they want you it
fill up on the salad and then they put
the seafood all the way at the end
because they want people to fill their
plates before they get the most
expensive item they'll attract you with
the expensive thing but they'll put it
at the end of your self-service line you
have the yogurt which is the highest
margin first and then you'll have your
dry items that don't go bad crumpled
Oreos things like that and then you have
the fresh fruit that goes bad that costs
more money by ounce and so they get
people to fill up their cup in the
beginning with the highest margin then
they sprinkle on a little bit of
slightly lower margin and then when you
have almost no room left then you put
your few fruit on top if you get a pound
of strawberries it's like 10 bucks
you put that pound on the machine ounces
there cost you 60 cents they'd be pretty
much breaking even on that corporate
noted that the number one way that they
are able to get more customers and the
highest performing stores did so with
better service cleaner stores more
selection and the most important one
word of mouth when you have an average
ticket that's so low like yogurt cups
and you have margin even on that tiny
little cup the only profitable way to
really acquire customers is either word
of mouth or Affiliates meaning other
businesses that send you business they
double down on that now when they
started years ago Google search was
cheap enough that they could actually
drive pay-per-click campaigns to get
people to their locations but nowadays
it's too expensive for most of them so
they almost all have to rely on the
quality of the product and the
experience the way that I was going to
open my store was that I wanted to
create a better experience for somebody
walked in I wanted to have
floor-to-ceiling kind of candy
see-through experiences and when someone
walked in they were overwhelmed and they
would just turn turn the nozzle on there
which by the way I would have it so
they'd be really clunky so too much
would fall through so I get a little bit
more water on it and I always felt like
that you should have more selection
people eat more the more options you
give them then my promotional effort my
plan was to go to the university so I
wanted to be close to colleges and then
I was going to partner with all of the
fraternities and sororities and have
competitions between them to see who
could get the most yogurt and then give
some sort of Swag or something for the
fraternity or whatever that got the most
yogurt during that period of time I
could rinse and repeat that process with
companies I could rinse and repeat that
process with affiliations and that is
the cheapest form of advertising when
you don't have a lot of money is going
to find places where there's buckets of
people that you can give them some sort
of promotion to bring them in I'd run
the competitions to bring them in I'd
have a crazy incentive to get the text
number like hey do you want to save 50
today by joining your text list I just
acquired a lead that I can get lifetime
value on for two dollars
I'll take it because I know that I'm
going to be able to get them back or get
them to bring a friend and I want to be
able to remind them of my store on a
regular basis so if you're looking at
stuff that you can model from the yogurt
businesses and also not do that they're
doing poorly number one when you have
the option to give a customer the
ability to pick their own pricing by
usage do it oftentimes people will blame
themselves not you when they overuse or
overspend think about minutes back in
the day or text messages number two you
want the most people to see the thing
that makes you the most money first we
want to use up as much of their spending
power on the things that make us the
most profit number three if you have a
type of product or service where someone
can sample multiple things the more
things you offer them the more things
that they will ultimately buy and
consume number four if you are starting
a business unless it's something brand
new and completely radical there's
likely somebody who started a business
just like yours who failed and you can
oftentimes buy all their stuff for 10
cents or five cents on the dollar and
and dramatically decrease your startup
cost if you can get a decent amount of
actual equipment for that amount of
money when you go to the right seller
and that is a motivated seller number
five the power of the default option the
fact that they went from removing the
tiny cups to only giving large and
bucket sized cups for yogurt encourage
people to use more yogurt themselves and
they do that because it looks silly in
comparison six when you're trying to
promote something that costs very little
money especially consumer products it's
very difficult to acquire customers with
paid advertising profitably that's why a
lot of these places raise funding if you
don't have tons of cash and you're not
funded then the two most profitable
strategies for acquiring customers you
get Word of Mouth which is referrals
it's not just having a very good product
which is important but reminding and
encouraging people to share it my
podcast I just decided to say hey guys
if you could leave a review and share
this with somebody that would be great
as soon as we did that we 20xed the
number of reviews that we were getting
and our growth skyrocketed just because
I asked by the way click subscribe and
notification Bell and all those things
and share those fantastic